belgium is returning the remains of the
icon of congo's anti-colonial movement
to his family
a single tooth is all that is believed
to remain at patrice lumumba after his
assassination in 1961.
an official ceremony to hand back the
tooth is being held in brussels we'll
speak to our correspondent there after
this report on who patrice lumumba was
and how he died
in this art studio in brussels stands
one of the greatest figures of the
african independence movement
this larger than life-size statue of
patrice lumumba is a tribute to him from
the congolese community in belgium
lumumba played a significant role in the
transformation of the congo from a
belgian colony into an independent
republic
uh patrice lumumba fought for the
freedom of his country and he was killed
for that
and
the the country never really recovered
from that loss until today patrice
lumumba became the congo's first prime
minister after regained independence in
1960 but he was only in office for a few
months before he fell out with the
country's former colonial ruler which
led to him being ousted in a coup
imprisoned tortured and later executed
ludo divitter is a belgian author who
wrote a book about lumumba's murder
the book reveals the belgian
government's complicity
and details how lumumba and two of his
associates were executed in a forest and
how their bodies were disposed it was
done during the night so there were a
lot of
villagers who
were very suspicious and so uh very
quickly um belgians and categories
decided to dig up the bodies and to have
the body completely destroyed and so
they cut them into pieces
and
dissolved them into a barrel of
um
sulfuric acid a belgian officer who was
involved later confirmed the book's
account
including the part about him removing
lumumba's tooth and keeping it as a
trophy
after the release of the book in 91 a
parliamentary commission of inquiry
concluded that belgium had quote moral
responsibility for lumumba's killing
activism has continued here to force the
country to fully recognize and atone for
its brutal colonial past that led to the
deaths of millions in the drc
there's been some progress
after years of activism and debate the
brussels municipality opened this square
named after and in honor of patrice
lumumba authorities said that the
symbolic gesture was intended to reflect
belgium's colonial past activists now
use the space to tell people about
patrice lumumba's life and legacy the
the main thing
that he was assassinated for
was to erase him politically
and to erase his memory so
having the square is a
a way of reviving his
his memory patrice lumumba's tooth is
all that was left of him after he was
killed
belgium returning it to his family is
being welcomed as a first step we hope
it to be the beginning of the
recognition that colonialism was
something wrong was a crime against
humanity and that we can start to
install
a kind of political preparation it's
taken decades for the truth about the
circumstances of patrice lumumba's
murder to emerge congolese people at
home and abroad hope it'll take less
time for their nation
and their hero to get justice
and on location at patisserie square
where the ceremony is taking place is dw
correspondent christine mundo who filed
that report uh christine tell us about
what's happening the ceremony today
so nick patrice lumumba's tooth has been
in the belgian prosecutor's office here
in brussels since 2016 when it was taken
from the daughter of the officer who had
held it as a trophy
in 2020 at the height of the black lives
matter protests uh the king finally
responded to a letter by patrice
lumumba's daughter where she was asking
or had been asking for the return of her
father's remains and of course
bureaucracy the pandemic led to several
delays and the day has finally come
the family is going to be received by a
delegation of
brussels belgian officials
headed by the prime minister the federal
prosecutor himself is going to hand over
the tooth
that was it's been placed and specially
made casket and was brought to the venue
in a hearse
and how significant is this ceremony uh
to to belgium is it the country's moment
of reckoning with its colonial past do
you think
well nick the the belgian prime minister
said that this was a turning point uh
for for he for this country's relations
with its former uh colony the congo but
just recently the belgian royals were in
the congo and the king whilst they
expressed uh what he called was his
deepest regrets for for the colonial era
we're talking about a time where about
10 million congolese people are said to
have died of starvation they were they
were killed of disease uh in the first
23 years of belgium's uh rule in the
congo he expressed his deep regrets but
he didn't apologize uh so a lot of
people are questioning uh the the
sincerity uh of all of this um we also
have to point out uh nick that uh beyond
uh this this returning of these remains
uh the congo uh is is in deep distress
after the murder and murder offer
patrice lumumba a dictatorship that
lasted over 30 years followed
where the contin country continued to be
pillaged and people in the congo see
that as a result of belgium's
involvement those who were involved in
the murder of patrice rumumba uh were
never prosecuted uh themselves so
there's a lot of skepticism but some do
hope that this is the start
of something wider well thank you for
being with us on this historic day dw
correspondent christine mundo
you